como es el estado de la economía
británica que se encontrará listas en
este inicio de mandato y que reto se
afrontará
hola buenas tardes trigo como estas
bueno yo creo que el estrés tiene unos
muy pocos días ahora es a partir de hoy
lunes para definir quiénes van a ser sus
ministros sobre todo en los portafolios
más importantes y ya se entrena con con
desafíos muy enormes en términos
económicos la inflación obviamente y las
presiones que está sufriendo la moneda
la libra esterlina y cómo generar
energía en el reino unido en el mar del
norte por ejemplo cómo explorar cómo ha
cambiado el discurso ambientalista
también y cómo van a mejor manejar las
relaciones con la rusia de putin en las
próximas semanas y meses si por una
parte atrás ha prometido un gran paquete
de ayudas pero por otra promete también
una gran rebaja de impuestos son medidas
compatibles o tendrá que renunciar
algunas de ellas al menos en parte
a mí me parece muy muy difícil realmente
cumplir con estas promesas promesas que
el strass ha hecho durante estas últimas
semanas de campaña y seguramente ya se
ve como una heredera de margaret
thatcher
quiere bajar los impuestos
quieren menos regulación y normas pero
al mismo tiempo ya tiene que darse
cuenta que la deuda pública de reino
unido obviamente es altísima entonces en
esta coyuntura también pensando en las
altas tasas de inflación ya tiene que
manejar el crecimiento económico a un
lado y al otro lado vean como ella
realmente puede atacar estas altas tasas
de inflación
si atrás tiene por el momento la mitad
de la legislatura antes y aún dos años
de mandato pero la campaña electoral
comenzaría ya durante su último año hoy
por hoy y bajo esta coyuntura cuáles son
las perspectivas del partido conservador
antes que nada el estrés tiene una tarea
enorme energía establecer la confianza
de los votantes británicos en el partido
conservador y esta confianza
ha sufrido un montón en los en los
últimos meses dado las mentiras y la
falta de transparencia y honestidad
temores jones él todavía actual primer
ministro
entonces eso va a ser un reto pero lo
positivo para atrás es que como usted
acaba de decir ya todavía habría por lo
menos tendría dos años más en esta
legislatura probablemente ya también
pensando en pacificar su partido tiene
que elegir muy bien los futuros
ministros ahora en estos próximos días